hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva and
I'm the kind of we're gonna watch eight
perfect movie castings that went
horribly wrong this is from the channel
what culture one of my favorite channels
of all time I think they make some of
the best list videos they're actually
kind of funny this video together
sometimes I'll make a couple of those
yeah I mean we were time we were doing
it get him out of them we haven't done
one in a while we just did a favorite
game of Thrones characters nice yeah oh
dude is our most watched video 3,000
views doing incredibly well right people
are always like oh I'm so glad this
isn't a reaction I'm glad it is you're
doing now if we did a reaction to
someone else's token to one culture the
term perfect casting is a strange little
saying in it's intense it refers to a
time when I film manages to find an
actor so suited to the role that it
would be impossible to imagine it done
better like Heath Ledger as the Joker or
your mum in old and dry but well worth
the try number five that being said as
so many times we've been presented with
air quotes perfect fits which just ended
up being terrible so you know the drill
let's have a look at some of the worst
today with this in mind I'm Jules your
Southwest savage haven't slept very well
and these are eight perfect casting
decisions that went horribly wrong event
Christian Bale as John Connor oh great
expect a lot from his performance as
John Connor in Terminator Salvation
unfortunately thanks to a sloppy
incoherent script to focus bales
presence was all but completely wasted
in a generic and something that the one
thing most people remember about
salvation is Bell's notorious on-screen
grunts a performance that was more
[Laughter]
that's the right II know that's you know
I just love the I am Trevor moment that
annoyed people so very much that being
said I can definitely see the casting
and then switching Kingsley was a waste
of his monumental talent the first
armored the film builds the Mandarin
beautifully as this ruthless warlord
only to see it all fouler than Trevor's
bathroom upon release of course we can't
blame Kingsley for this sadly perfect
casting going horribly wrong he does his
best to handle the switch but it's the
tone shifting hands of shame black
director who should bear the brunt of
our hire who took a fearsome character
and turned him into a wet part of a joke
yeah six Tom Hanks as Professor gh door
The Ladykillers
kinda like him in this movie but I've
heard success The Ladykillers
and you're trying to find someone to
take on the role of Professor Marcus the
snide insincere lead you should probably
find somebody with the acting chops that
even stand close to the likes of Alec
Guinness now tom hanks is such a man
whether he's on an island or it's what a
second it's a steam train the trouble
was that the Coen brothers thought that
maybe they should oh yeah undo all of
the characters traits that made the
original so great in that they didn't
making creepy didn't give him those odd
teeth and instead just made him dispute
toilet humor that is a hard pass for me
thank you kindly Lee Jones as Harvey
Dent
two-face never going to win any awards
for what it does with the Batman law
except maybe providing the
weirdest-looking Gotham City known to
date it's such a shame as the talent on
the rogues gallery site is phenomenal
with potential serial killer no
seriously he said he'd be killing people
if he wasn't acting Jim Carrey and
monolith of wrinkles Tommy Lee Jones
it was tlj performance that was the most
disappointing however as it appeared he
didn't get the memo to play to face and
instead seemingly was channeling the
Chokey yeah it's not a bad Joker per se
but this wasn't the role for him no
which is annoying really because when
you've got a voice like a shar-pei puppy
get the right look and presence to pull
off a decent to face and before Johnny
Depp has Willy Wonka I kind of like it
yet I don't like it I like a check it's
really when you're comparing it with
your demo well we can't say that Johnny
Depp didn't bring everything to the
forefront of what made his other
characters so great the problem was that
while his oddball nature and pond Shawn
for weirdness appears to be a perfect
choice on paper no one seemed to mention
that while Wonka is as emotionally
stable as my last relationship he's not
repressed to the point of mundanity
his outbursts depression seemed to be so
much more harsh than Wilders fluctuating
madness and meant that Wonka just came
across like an [ __ ] for the majority
Giamatti at Rhino the amazing spider-man
2 don't heart an amazement totally
different movie three minutes of screen
time as a villain with more potential
than your actual main body yeah this
should be obvious right at one point
there were big plans for the Rhino with
a view to update his character and move
onwards with a sinister six theme but
sadly this was reduced to the bookending
narrative with all the punch of weak
wrists man fighting goth big wall that
number two Michael Shannon has general
so bad but the issue was that while his
tone was psychopathic and powerful
that's all it was
fans that the comics will know that song
is a lot deeper than just being an angry
space dude and the film even gave like
two motivations much deeper than kill
all and Beale
yes for some reason the Shan man was set
to 100% pissed and all his like it was
the result of being told the boom mic
operator is on another very monotone
such a shame and number one Christoph
Waltz as Ernst Stavro Blofeld Spectre so
this entry is kind of like a
self-fulfilling prophecy
younger bond fans might not know of the
importance of blog post but by Gomez has
announced appearance in the run-up to
does release a big deal it was made even
bigger thanks to Walt's taking up the
role because I mean let's face it when
has he ever turned in a bad run well
here I guess but I mean it's not
terrible but it's just really
underwhelming
bland but an actor with more pedigree
than Triple H across there you should
probably give him room to actually get
your character across because of being
undeveloped before the twist reveal all
we really feel for the later half his
performance is it would play catch up to
someone rather than growing to fear them
yes it's actually too good at his job
and that he delivers Annie a perfect
example of what an older Bond villain
should be yet that's the issue older
because every other aspect of the Bond
franchise has been updated to move with
the times and this felt like too much of
a throwback which ultimately left us
with something that felt like it blow
found hums and that's all it's got any
other perfect casting choices that fell
a little flat well let me know about
them in the comments section below
and why not swing about what culture
come for more news and articles like
this every goddamn day as always I've
been Jules you've been awesome I'll
speak to you soon
I would say Jared Leto as the Joker oh
yeah I thought Jared Leto of like when I
heard he was cast I wasn't like whoa
probably a really good choice of
actually yeah yeah that was a pretty big
letdown I've seen Suicide Squad twice
and I saw the extended cut I like him
even less the extra scene I saw and I
thought this list was great I loved that
topic
oh yeah you know that happens so
frequent Christian Bale is John Connor
man I could go on and on about that
because even when they talked about the
rent poor when he gave his apology for
it I did believe him and I still do he
was so in the zone of John Connor
you know a lot of that was coming out
well I think he is truly yeah he says
he's a mom yeah he's a phenomenal actor
he was a great Batman but he would so
actually he'd be a great Joker I saw the
trailer for salvation I'm like yes he
looks good in this movie and then I
watched the film and I couldn't stand
him I couldn't I was honestly annoyed by
him and I don't blame it solely on the
writing and directing which is also not
good Sam Worthington is in the film and
he does a great job yeah fantastic
I feel sad because Sam hasn't gone No
so Edwards has been so many big movies
and like no one seems to like ya but
Christian Bale in that movie yeah that's
that was such a solid choice here
because I did feel that like perfect
casting and then you watch it you're
like wow he's really annoying in this
movie but again I think with a lot of
these roles that I don't even know if
it's necessarily even their fault a lot
of a lot of times especially like with
Ben Kingsley with Ironman it's very much
just how it's written it's not always
the fault of the actor but that being
said John Connor was like you know like
built up for so many years as this you
know guy who like epic leader yeah
resistance yeah and then he was just
kind of like he was Batman voice he says
every single line in that movie or he
occasionally yells Ben Kingsley though
because of the topic on this list I get
why he's here but it really was the
writing and the direction of that film
because when I first saw Iron Man 3 I
hated that twist I did yeah I think
everyone did yeah
when I rewatched it I liked it because I
knew it was coming so I was able to
accept the context of what the entirety
was and I and I enjoyed the twist and I
think Ben Kingsley does a really good
job as the Mandarin and he does a really
good job as his trevor guy he showed
just how great of an actor he is in that
movie it's just I think the problem is
is it's already shared universe yeah
connected to comic books if Shane black
and I said this and then I said this in
one of my videos at one point if Shane
black made this as a standalone original
film separate from you know yeah it
being connected to the like and with her
Joker movie yeah yeah yeah it would
probably had gone over much better than
it did it's just that you're already
attached to seeing that and there's
expectations and the Mandarin is like
the Iron Man villain yeah Iron Man yeah
apart and what was disappointed about it
was because Ben Kingsley was fantastic
the man has whatever his crazy character
yeah is he at the end there yeah yeah he
had the quotes from the trailer that we
were all digging yeah we're like man
he's gonna kill it as the manor you know
you gotta respect to twist in a sense
cuz you're like yeah I didn't see that
coming
at same time they were like I kind of
just wish she was the manner as far as
to face with with bad law he really was
trying to be the Joker it was very very
obvious there was like that's not it's
not to face Thank You face there's two
characters there but he was pretty much
just playing the one loud over the novel
and I'm like dude you already got Jim
Carrey here please dial it back a little
bit again that's not necessarily his
fault I mean but are we sure about that
are we sure about okay i'm gonna blame
him a little bit for that but the
schumacher is kind of loud obnoxious
made the whole thing very cartoonish to
begin with it yeah I mean it's not that
Batman is a real character but we want
the real movie a virile people to feel
somewhat real he was just a cartoon
character
yeah especially because Harvey Dent was
a DA who developed split personality a
man has dual identity yeah a subtle
performance would have been way better
especially with the Tommy Lee Jones kind
of actor Oscar winning actor Tommy Lee
Jones instead doing that was obnoxious
and annoying how you're hearing
frustrating to sit through actually very
frustrating I don't sit through it I
don't I'd actually never revisit and
then when you have like scenes with like
the Riddler and that two-face oh I'm
getting a headache Willy Wonka yeah let
me just say I loved I still loved
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory I think
it's a fantastic movie just don't
compare to the original because it's not
and I don't think that Johnny Depp was
terrible in that it's just there was
potentially better choices out there
than Johnny Depp like who
Dustin Hoffman that would been amazing
actually and I think it's unfortunately
a curse that's associated with Johnny
Depp sometimes joined up being the lead
in a Tim Burton film isn't always the
best choice I think he could've easily
played one of the parents there could
have been another role for him in there
that would have been equally but I know
that he's Johnny Depp and we want to
highlight him and I think it's it's hard
because we already have a really
and you don't want to make him the same
as the other guy sure the same time like
he wasn't creepy the way that Gene
Wilder was oh no no not at all I see I
only saw Willy Wonka Chocolate Factory
once in great school you're kidding me I
never rewatched it oh wow I remember
like enough of it like the fingers
crossed behind the back yeah it's my
all-time favorite movies yeah yeah a lot
of people say that yeah so I don't have
this nostalgia love for Willy Wonka in
the Chocolate Factory that I feel like
most people I know possess sure sure
someone they gonna try the Chocolate
Factory it's like what are you doing
Johnny Depp no I don't feel that it was
very easy for me to adjust to the weird
Tim Burton style so Johnny Depp did you
in waka and I enjoyed him I thought he
was funny as you like him better as
Willy Wonka or as the Mad Hatter Willy
Wonka really I don't like that you like
this yeah I might get crap for it
I cannot tell you 100% what makes Gene
Wilder's such an amazing performance
because I don't really remember the
movie I remember is a very sincere much
more subtle performance I loved that
like this is such a creepy weird dude
who I grew to like I feel like the first
half of this movie I don't like Willy
Wonka but by the end I'm like oh I get
why this guy is the weirdo he is and I
feel like it's because it's Charlie's
perspective of him of why I've been able
to like him so but as opposed to you
know Gene Wilder's you're like oh it's
just likeable up front I feel like if
you take out Willy Wonka's character and
you just look at the movie it's a dark
twisted fairy tale of a film no it's
fine which the original doesn't feel
like with the way Tim Burton's feels
like Johnny Depp's Willy Wonka fits in
with that that's a fair our canyons our
objective you must accept mine I accept
Michael Shannon as Zod I mean I'm not
too familiar with his odd comic-book
character but I thought he was fine
really Man of Steel oh I figured you
knew all about him people think and stop
thinking this about no I thought he was
great I actually liked a Man of Steel I
actually liked
I like my steel I thought it was a good
Superman movie and I was not upset at
all with the subtle changes that they
made to the yeah I thought he was a
great villain and I thought he was
compelling and menacing and actually one
I don't think it was this one note
performance at what culture is sort of
making it out to be every time I see one
of the list videos there's always like
one thing I'm like I disagree I mean he
was angry but he was also trying to work
with Clark Kent's character and Lodging
of money in spider-man the amazing
spider-man 2 oh dude I feel really bad
for Paul Giamatti for that role well is
he was he was in a totally different
film
I love spider-man he was what Tommy Lee
Jones was in Batman Forever but for like
30 seconds an amazing sight
I don't think you understand what what
the tone of this movie's supposed to be
I mean hey I don't really like that
movie to begin with no it's terrible and
I'm saying that I love spider-man it's
in this ring because I've heard when I
first saw it I was like it's alright and
then when I rewatched is like I can't
stand this I left the theater just being
like I don't know why I'm upset I just
saw spider-man movie but I'm really
upset right now I think that he was
actually one of the better villains in
the movie really it means something
we're where they're going for like
realistic subtle stuff but whenever
their characters turn into villains they
become so over-the-top like Harry Osborn
is Green Goblin becomes so over-the-top
or Jamie Foxx is electro if you just
Jamie Foxx's snacks in the movie yeah I
kind of over the top and then like I
don't I don't understand why when they
become villains they're so over-the-top
you're trying to go for like this is the
more realistic interpretation is
spider-man yeah yeah the originals
didn't do that quite as bad until like
the third one it killed the franchise
but thank God it did because I mean that
in the leak and soon you got it but
we're getting off topic but thank God
for that spider-man yeah edge well do
you Monty
feel bad well Paul Giamatti can be a
little over the top in general but I
mean Rhino is a character that's
ridiculous anyway he's yeah silly in the
in the comic books like no one ever
takes him seriously yeah well he doesn't
totally fit in with the movie though no
so that means very crowded yeah I was
really underwhelmed
I'm kind of sick Christoph Waltz playing
bad guys but at least when he plays bad
guys he's entertaining yeah that's kind
of where I'm at with Christoph kind of
there with hobby of our damned - I
filming on a sick of it I felt like
Christoph Waltz in that movie basically
they were just spent the entire time
with his villain going I'm someone
important and he's so dull ya know he's
so dull like I felt like him and Daniel
Craig both did not want to be in that
movie I don't know why they just didn't
give their a-game in that film both of
them did it let me just get these lines
down get my page yeah that's exactly
what it felt like I'm contractually
obligated in terms of like writing it
really relies on you enjoying who
Christoph Waltz is playing if you saw a
Bond movie that's like 20 Bond movies
Wow it's great that you're paying homage
to your classic it doesn't feel like it
takes place now it didn't feel like it
was reaching its audience because most
of its audience now are younger yeah
didn't they don't recognize all this
fondly I feel like most of us probably
started from Pierce Brosnan and that's
just States fact it's if you know
there's plenty of you out there who have
seen no it's so true the tea doll and
the Sean Connery and the Roger Moore I
actually watch I've been watching them
from the beginning I watched those
movies with my dad all the time but the
ones that really stood out originally
for me were the Pierce Brosnan movies
with Goldeneye and so on yeah yeah it
doesn't make sense that they went this
route with this movie and like in terms
of Spectre - like I just gotta say like
the first two movies Spectre is like the
consistency between those two doctor
knows from Spectre and then the sequel
is Spectre once revenge
yeah so then the fact that they were
like oh they're finally bring an
inspector into the Daniel Craig ones
this is huge just I say Quantum sauce is
the worst one of the Democratic ones but
I think Spectre is the most
disappointing one sure because Quantum
of Solace had all like the writers
issues and all that I think that what
they're trying what they were trying to
do with this movie was almost like what
star trek into darkness was trying to do
or they were trying to bring back
through their big character and like
yeah you know
con no no just do your own thing at this
point I mean this is sort of an
alternate an alternate timeline anyway I
mean it's very much is it's the most
confusing origin
it's an origin tale but it takes place
many years after all the other gone what
yeah well thanks for culture for making
a really solid list that was that was
actually it was it really like a great
topic cuz I feel like you know normally
list videos are pretty like easy to go
to topics and but there's like an
interesting topic and with a great list
assemble for it thank you well coasters
provided a list you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell follow the Kyler man on Instagram
and Twitter a part of the fan theory
YouTube channel not just part of the
head of this star of he is everything
for it and go check out our patreon
become a patron eject today